[موسيقى]
سينقذ في بيتي في منزله في الشقه التي
كانت بالنسبه له ربما
ترتبط بذكريات كبيره لانه كان يقيم في
ولايه نيويورك بعدما قرر هجرها تماما
والاقامه في ولايه فلوريدا
[موسيقى]
سيف يقف امام القاضي وسوف يعرض عليه
القاضي قراءه التهم الموجهه اليه ونتوقع
ان تكون نحو 34 تهمه 34 تهمه بالتحديد
وبعد ذلك سيقوم بتوزيعها على
المحامين حيث ليست لديهم نسخه من هذه
التهم حتى الان وعلى الادعاء وسنعلم جميعا
ما هي هذه التهم
غدا بعد لقائه مع محاميه سيمتل امام
المحكمه وبعد مثول طبعا لفتره قصيره
سيتوجه الى مره اخرى الى فلوريدا لنتوقع
الخطاب الاهم ربما في بالنسبه للرئيس
ترامب وهو خطاب وجوه للشعب الامريكي
لمؤيده ولمناصريه ليقول بان هذه التهم
باطله
[موسيقى]